[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be discussing probably the single
most popular and requested topic in the
comment sections of our boku no hero
videos and that is the real reason why
that goos father still hasn't appeared
in the story including both the anime
and the manga I have to say that we have
gotten a ton of support from you guys on
our boku no hero videos lately and I am
extremely grateful for that and I can
tell you from reading the comments that
a lot of you really wanted me to talk
about the real reason behind dec whose
fathers absence so because you requested
it in this video I'll be doing just that
I will be talking about all the most
popular theories about the true identity
of Dec whose father from theories that
he is just an ordinary guy to theories
that he's actually a villain and even
theories claiming that dec whose mom has
been deliberately lying about the dad
this whole time and at the end of the
video I will give you my personal
opinion on the real reason that dec
whose dad is still missing from the
story by the way I realized that these
images are not of Dec whose father they
are Dec who disguised as an adult but
because we haven't seen Dec whose father
and we have no idea what he looks like I
thought that Dec whose cosplay would be
cool to use and it would be pretty funny
if Dec whose dad actually looked like
this I mean let's be real in this
disguise Deku kinda looks like a shady
guy on the street who tried to sell you
a fake Rolex but anyways to start with I
will be addressing some of the theories
that I got from you guys on Twitter and
Instagram and if you want to weigh in
after watching this video feel free to
follow me at anime uproar and if I get
some really good responses I will make
another video talking about them
and of course if you enjoyed this type
of content and you want to see more you
can let me know by leaving a like and if
you have it to be new to the channel
feel free to subscribe and Detroit smash
that notification valve by the way there
will be some season 3 spoilers in this
video for you anime only fans but
nothing beyond season 3 content if you
don't want any spoilers whatsoever you
have been warned so what's
do we know about that whose dad we know
that his name is Hisashi midoriya that
he is legally married to that Kuzma Inc
oh and that he works outside of japan we
also know that he has a quirk which
allows him to breathe fire
his name he's a she is a play on words
in Japanese and when combined with booty
to form Hisashi booty it essentially
works out - it's been a while since I've
seen you last this tells us that the
author of MH Aiko hey horikoshi is well
aware that dec whose father's absence
will be noticed by the fans and he is
having a little bit of fun with it and
that leads us to the very first theory
which is that dec whose dad is just an
ordinary person now I've seen a lot of
people talk about how suspicious it is
for dec whose dad to leave his family
for a long time and work overseas and
because of this they often conclude that
there is something else going on however
I have to say that in Japan it is
actually not that unusual for someone to
work in another country or travel a lot
for work as you probably know Japan is
home to many large international
companies from Sony and Toshiba to
Kawasaki and Honda and that's only
naming a few all of these companies have
offices in many countries throughout the
world and it is not unusual for a
Japanese employee in one of these
companies to be sent abroad for a longer
period of time so is it possible that
horikoshi is going to just bring dec
whose dad into the story at some point
in the future and that he will indeed
turn out to be just a regular guy it's
definitely possible and horikoshi could
be having a blast watching people
theorize about the father's true
identity when in reality there is
nothing special about him at all
feliks on twitter believes this to be
the case and mika holland thinks that
dec whose father may never become
relevant in the story which would be
kind of cool as it would emphasize that
the greatest hero doesn't necessarily
need a lineage of greatness to be great
himself but on the other hand if we look
at other popular shown in series like
naruto maggie and one-piece we know that
it is also possible that the main
character's father will turn out to be
someone
very important this has happened many
times before the next theory is that Dec
whose father is actually the flame hero
endeavor aka ng Todoroki show toes
father this theory has become popular
because endeavour has a fire based quirk
and we know that Dec whose dad also has
a fire based quirk aka breathing fire or
s cosplay mentioned this theory on
Instagram and it's been brought up many
times before in the comments those who
believe in this theory often say that
since endeavour is so cruel to his
family it isn't a stretch to think that
he might have cheated on his wife and
secretly fathered deku but personally I
do not buy this theory and here's why
for one endeavour is a celebrity one of
the top-ranked pro heroes so if he was
dec whose father and dec who didn't
realize it then it would mean that dec
whose mother Inco has been lying to him
and manipulating him for his entire life
but come on just look at that face
is that the face of someone who would
lie and manipulate her own son I mean
look at her she is so freaking cute and
adorable I am a crying shut up anyway
another reason why I don't buy this
theory is that although it is true that
quirks are often passed down from
parents to children in some capacity
there are plenty of characters in the
story who have similar quirks but don't
appear to be related like Kirishima and
Tetsu Tetsu both having hardening quirks
and not to mention that water-based
quirks are possessed by a number of
people including Koda and his parents
but also other Pro heroes like manual
and backdraft who don't seem to be
related to Koda in any way next up is
the theory that Dec whose father is
actually all might according to this
theory the real reason why Almighty
picked Deku out of all people to inherit
one for all is because Deku is actually
his son those who believe in this theory
point out that all might was also born
worthless so this is something that dec
who could have inherited from his
alleged father and over on Twitter Luna
mentioned this theory and suggested that
may be the reason why inco and Toshi
nori kept the truth hidden
that cou all this time is because they
want to protect him since we all know
that the family of the symbol of peace
would be a major target for villains I
could see where this type of logic is
coming from but for this to be true it
presupposes the deck whose mom ink oh
and all might have both been carrying on
an elaborate charade around deku this
entire time because their interactions
in the anime and manga suggests that
Inco and all might have no prior
relationship all might also would have
been famous even back when Deku was a
baby so unless Toshi nori used his small
might form to seduce ink oh and she
wasn't aware who he was this theory
would require the kind of elaborate
cover-up that I just don't think either
Inco or all might are capable of and if
this were the case then what about he
sashimi Daria did inko just make him up
or is he just some guy that thinks Deku
is his son but really isn't
again I think ginkgo is way too nice and
sincere of a person to be a part of
something like this look at that face
and then we have the theory that Dec
whose dad is a villain this is an
extremely popular theory in the comments
sections of our videos and it basically
states that the reason Dec whose father
is away is that he is busy being a
villain Ethan mentioned this theory on
Twitter and MZ lambchops mentioned it on
Instagram in this scenario
he says she lied to his family that he
was taking a job abroad while in reality
he is leading a secret life as a villain
and presumably inko would not be aware
of the truth so this takes away the need
for encode to be part of some massive
cover-up to be honest this would
definitely be a plausible twist to the
story I've seen quite a few people
saying that perhaps Dec whose father
will turn out to be the final villain in
the series and Decker will have to
defeat him even though fighting his own
father will pose a huge internal
conflict for him and this would then
provide exactly the type of drama that
is needed for a great final arc I get
the feeling that half of the MHA fanbase
would like this kind of twist and the
other half would hate it and see it as
too predictable but either way it would
definitely be a way to bring extra drama
and in turn
conflict into the story my own take on
this theory is that although there is no
evidence it is plausible and similar
twists have happened before in popular
shown and series still this is not my
personal theory next we have the theory
that the coos dad is not just any
villain he is in fact all for one this
is another very popular theory and as
all for one has finally made his
appearance in season three of the anime
I am noticing more and more people
suggesting that all for one could be Dec
whose father gunvolt had this idea on
Twitter and will rupee had the same idea
on Instagram
the origins of this theory stemmed from
a few factors including the fact that
deck was doctored the one who told him
that he doesn't have a quirk appears to
be the same doctor who works directly
for all for one I discussed this in
greater detail in a previous video about
Deku potentially having been born with a
quirk that was stolen before he realized
he had it and I will link that video in
the description if you want to check it
out the gist of it is that according to
this theory the doctor who works for
all-4-one was the same doctor who was
seeing Deku because all-4-one wanted to
keep an eye on his son and perhaps the
doctor stole deck whose work because
all-4-one wanted to keep his son out of
danger by preventing him from becoming a
hero presumably all-4-one would have
gotten together with Inco before
sustaining his terrible injuries so he
would have looked like a normal person
and could have introduced himself as a
guy named Hisashi midoriya
and encode would have just accepted it
without realising his true identity we
know that all-4-one has lived for many
generations he created the original one
for all quark which was already passed
down for nine generations if we include
Deku so we can safely assume that all
for one at some point stole a quark that
allowed him to live way beyond one
lifetime and perhaps even stay young
forever so inco could have thought that
he was just a normal man her age all for
once injuries would also explain why he
hasn't returned to his family for so
many years the way he looks now after
his big battle with all might five or
six
earlier he certainly could not fool inko
into thinking that he was just a regular
guy all-4-one has also often been
compared to Darth Vader because he wears
a dark mask as a result of injuries he
sustained in his past similarly to Vader
so some people believe that just like
Luke finds out that Vader is his father
in Star Wars Decker will find out that
all for one is his father at a critical
time in the series
we know that horikoshi references Star
Wars often along with other Western
franchises like Marvel Comics so this
theory claims that all for one turning
out to be Dec whose father will just be
one of multiple parallels and homage as
to Star Wars in boku no hero even though
this theory might be a bit unoriginal
after Star Wars already did it I think
it could also be interesting if executed
well
I personally don't hate the idea but for
this to make sense there would have to
be some reason why all-4-one chose to
marry and have a child with Inco in
particular is there something special
about her that attracted him did he just
fall in love with her or was she someone
he picked at random because he wanted a
successor is this perhaps related to the
fact that Inca reminds all might of his
former mentor Nana Shimura who was
herself a former user of one for all and
she also just happens to be Shiga
Rocky's grandmother
but if Deku really is all for one son
then why don't we see all for one taking
more of an interest in Deku and instead
he seems to be really interested in
Shiga rocky and treats shigaraki like a
son ultimately I think that the theory
that all for one is Deku Father is
pretty unlikely although still more
likely than both the endeavor and all my
theories and finally we have the theory
that decos dad is some sort of
undercover agent my own theory is that
if Deku stat is not just an ordinary guy
and it is entirely possible that he is
then he is probably some type of special
hero who works as a secret agent or
undercover agent either in another
country or even in Japan
and so the real reason why dec whose dad
is missing from the story is that as an
undercover agent he is forced to keep
his real life a secret and keep
communication with his real family to a
minimum otherwise he might arouse
suspicion from the people he is secretly
investigating I came up with this theory
because I feel that dec whose dad
turning out to be an undercover agent
would be one of the few legitimate ways
to explain his absence in a way that
doesn't make him look bad
in this case Dec whose dad is not a
deadbeat or a villain he is doing
important work and fighting for justice
but his work is top-secret and dangerous
so he has to keep his family out of it
as much as possible it would be
especially interesting if Dec whose dad
was infiltrating a major group of
villains and pretending to be a villain
and so when he first finds out that COO
thinks that his dad really became a
villain and this causes a lot of tension
until later deku learns that his dad is
actually a good guy but he couldn't tell
him because of the nature of his job if
I had to pick a theory other than Dec
whose dad is just an ordinary guy
undercover agent or spy would be my
theory of choice although misty connect
CEA's theory that deku father is
actually giovanni from pokemon is a good
one too but let me know what you guys
think do you buy into any of the
theories mentioned in this video or do
you have a better theory of your own if
you do have a better theory be sure to
reply to the threads on Twitter and
Instagram at Anime uproar and let me
know I will mention my favorite
responses in a future video and if I
come across some particularly good
theories I might make a whole new video
on them if you enjoyed this video be
sure to leave a like to let me know if
you are new don't forget to subscribe
and Detroit smash that notification bell
as always thank you all so much for
watching and until next time see us
space Cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]